so there's been a lot of talk recently
about vaxxers but what i hear you ask
about axers i'm referring of course to
this man david axelrod who's here now to
promote and talk about his new book it's
called believer my 40 years in politics
it's a story about the life and times of
david axelrod and he's a journalist and
in politics and david we're gonna put
this book up on the shelf and say this
is a truly it's a memoir and it's about
the politics of our time but it's also
about as i said your life so this is
we're combining two great things this is
your life plus an obstacle course two
great things to taste which my life has
been so first we have right here now
what do you call this call this the kids
call this a typewriter load up the paper
and i'll tell you what we're going to do
you know how to work one of these i i
loaded it i think i really so first
obstacle course and we'll put some time
up on the clock here so we're going to
have to go fast
yeah you can do that you know what
you're doing yeah first thing is i'm
going to give you
a situation
and i want you to write a lead okay okay
so i'm going to wait a second just okay
i don't we'll do what we can yeah i'm
gonna read you the facts alrighty the
cubs are about to play the white sox in
game seven of the world series
carrie wood is a starting pitcher for
the cubs meanwhile their accusations of
rigging the game within the white house
the white sox clubhouse write us a lead
off of that
oh man you're a hunting hacker i'm a
hunted pecker yeah
okay all done tell us tell us how you
become an artiste you're no longer just
a scrappy reporter yes i'm your get that
to me pull that out in dramatic
newspaper style all right there you go
but you want i don't know if you can
read it i don't have my glasses a
century after the black sox scandal
allegations of cheating
have once again once again
this time you're going to write a
headline you know this is why we don't
have typewriters anymore but anyway go
ahead you're going to write a headline
here's the facts for the headline ready
donald trump has bought the willis tower
and it's getting renamed again
but nobody knows what the name is going
to be
that's all right i gotta say this is a
professional journal it's like no
hesitation
it's like starts well done you
are you standing right here yeah we're
gonna come right around here we're here
okay all right here we go here we go now
david this is your life this is your
life we know one of the most important
institutions in your life is a deli in
yes in chicago called manny's yes you're
in new york now we don't have manny's
here so we went to good delis though so
we went to katz's deli and got and got a
sandwich now there oh my god yes all
right now there's also some stuff in
your book about your being a little bit
defensive about some of your reputation
for being schlubby and having like stuff
all over your pants and shirts and ties
yeah so myth so the goal here is for you
to take three bites of this sandwich
without getting anything on your clothes
ready you know i got several stops after
this guys here we go three bites
three real
bites all right well we broke the
sandwich in half oh yeah yeah there we
go there's yeah
all right there's one there's a little
mustard on his hand but technically not
on his clothes right yeah
this is your life the clock's still
moving there's a little on his face but
again the clothes spotless very
very impressive you've got a napkin for
that and there we go
i need a tarp and now
this is your life
that's very very good very good yeah
it's nice
we move over to the pictorial part of
this is your life you stand right there
right on them okay
we're going to show you a picture and
you're going to see a little dialogue
here and you're going to have to respond
just in the moment from a situation in
your past
this is your life david axelrod here we
go
ah talk back in character yeah
uh oh really
oh really uh i know
this is we should tell people what we're
referring to yes
this is a total story this was a meeting
that i had with john edwards when i was
working with him as his media consultant
in 2004 there's a great deal of friction
within the campaign i was up in new
hampshire at a
focus group and i got a message that
senator edwards was in town and wanted
to meet with me and this was his uh
opening line and all of it was true
except for the you're still our guy all
right part of it
let me ask you this question john
edwards you've worked for rob
blagojevich you worked for a lot of
people is this the worst client you ever
had no you know what john edwards was
personally he was uh decent to me i i
never thought of him as a bad guy he was
generous to me he was the worst client
you've ever worked for the worst client
i ever worked for
god that's a hard question because it's
like
you know you forget the pain
uh and it's hard to remember
so uh
i don't know how to answer that what
about you have a clear answer for who is
the worst candidate spouse you've ever
worked for well yes he does yeah i
i look elizabeth edwards who uh you know
god rest her soul uh was a very very
hard person for me to deal with all
right let's move on here next one
fast forward a little bit to another
presidential cycle
yeah what did you say to that guy go
ahead what would you say to him in that
moment well what happened is uh we lost
the uh
we lost new hampshire primary as as the
the uh art
suggests we we're up eight in our last
track uh pluff or dave plouffe robert
gibbs our press secretary and i went up
to uh senator obama's room he was up
there with his wife we knocked on the
door because we wanted to share the news
with him alone yeah he came out in the
hallway
and uh and uh we said uh looks like i
think pluff said looks like we're gonna
be a little short yeah and he said what
happened right and you said and i uh
well there was a lot of movement in the
last
thing shifted in the last day but the
thing that i most remember about it is
him sort of smiling wandly and he leaned
against the wall and he said this is
going to go on for a while isn't it yeah
and of course we were embarked on the
longest uh nominating struggle in the
history of american politics he was he
was right about that now this is the
last blast from your past
here you go this big blast from your
past what would you say to this guy
right here
i would say
uh where'd you get that big dark
mustache you know uh i
the thing looks like an inchworm
this story ran with in chicago magazine
with the headline of the story was
hatchet man the rise of david axelrod
how did you get to be called a hatchet
man
well i think it was a poor choice of
words on the part of not as good a
headline
no but the sub head was the one that
hurt it said he looks like an unmade bed
said his mother
honestly that's what it said yeah yeah
it was uh thanks mom every son it was a
it was this was not my favorite piece
and the guy who wrote it who's also
passed away since then
every time i encountered him
he'd see me coming down the street he
crossed to the other side so i think he
knew how i felt about the piece david
which probably didn't dispel the hatchet
man
idea in his head congratulations on the
book again it's called
believer yes david axelrod are many
thanks also besides to david the
gramercy typewriter company that's on
fifth avenue here in new york for their
exquisite royal quiet deluxe and of
course david congratulations again on
the book thank you very much good to be
here